[Aplausos]
soy un biólogo y
por lo general mis charlas son de
ciencia hablo de transgénicos de
biotecnología
de matemática
pero el tema que voy a tocar ahora es
algo muy hondo muy personal
mi experiencia
la depresión
lo que pasa con la vida de uno cuando
uno tiene una situación incontrolable
fuera del control de uno que no para que
no cesa que empeora como vivir en esas
circunstancias
esta presentación empieza con una
ventana
una noche cuando vivía en santiago de
chile
4 de la mañana y yo lo que hacía era
mirar a la ventana
no porque la vista fuera preciosa porque
una vista maravillosa un paisaje
excelente no
yo miraba la ventana porque la ventana
parecía llamarme seducirme porque la
ventana me ofrecía una solución no más
dolor
yo había llegado hasta ese punto
cuando yo empiezo a sentir eso
cierro los ojos y me digo no esto no
puede continuar yo llegar hasta este
punto la noche entera tratando de no
pensar en eso
entendiendo que ya necesitaba ayuda que
la situación se me había salido de las
manos que estaba en un país extranjero
sin familia tenía amigos en los que me
costaba mucho confiar lo que sentía
porque en todas nuestras sociedades hay
una estigma muy fuerte con la salud
mental y la depresión decir que no está
deprimido que no tiene una enfermedad
mental es un tabú
y bueno salir en logre salir de eso
empecé a hablar con mis amigos me dieron
recomendaciones y
terminé en terapia con un psicólogo que
llego a la conclusión de que si bien la
terapia era necesaria también eran
necesarias medidas más fuertes
como los antidepresivos
esto también es aún más tabú para la
gente
te hace cambiar de personalidad te mata
te convierte en un zombie bueno mi
experiencia fue todo lo contrario me
permitió volver a ser quien yo era me
permitió entre la terapia y los fármacos
me devolvieron mi vida anterior me
permitieron enfocarme fundar mi propio
negocio
aceptar una propuesta de matrimonio que
había sido hecha pero que yo por orgullo
por miedo no había tomado
que los amor de mi vida lo había
encontrado y está aquí
junto a mí
y bueno
yo pensaba que ya se había acabado todo
ya tenía todo bajo control y me di
cuenta que a pesar de tener una buena
había arreglado todo tenía un esposo que
me amaba que yo adoraba y tenía bien
vivía bien
qué pasa que yo siento que me estoy
volviendo a deprimir que hay cosas que
me están
afectando y qué es lo que pasa bueno lo
que pasa es que yo soy venezolano
y nosotros la gran mayoría de nosotros
incluso los que estamos afuera lo que
hemos estado fuera por años tenemos un
dolor que no cesa
es un sufrimiento que todos los días a
veces cada hora cada semana cada mes
cada año está presente porque a decir
uno hasta se siente culpable de vivir
bien cómo está la familia de cómo están
los amigos de uno
antes cuando la gente emigraba podía
olvidar porque se iban y de vez en
cuando les llegaba una carta y van a ver
malas noticias se murió tu madre es
porque tu padre pero son cosas puntuales
dosificadas llegaba la carta y bueno ya
tenías tiempo de volver a tu nueva vida
adaptarte en el mundo del siglo 21 el
inmigrante no tiene esa opción
tenemos celulares tenemos computadoras
tenemos internet las malas noticias
llegan sin cesar llegan llegan llegan y
una situación como la de venezuela donde
tenemos 18 años de malas noticias y
donde la situación cada día es más
aterradora es el infierno en la tierra
básicamente no hay escapatoria por más
bien que tú estés por más exitoso
triunfador por maravillosa que sea tu
vida eso te termina afectando
toda la vida por más bien que nos vaya
la vivimos con incertidumbre esperando
tratando de pensar qué podemos hacer
y cuando yo me di cuenta de eso
de qué
si me limitaba simplemente a tratar de
cambiar mi entorno inmediato jamás iba a
poder vivir en paz jamás iba a poder
estar tranquilo porque de manera
realista yo no pienso que vaya a haber
ningún cambio en venezuela
ni a mediano ni a corto ni a largo plazo
el cambio va a ser para peor como
aprendió a vivir con eso por más fuerte
que sea la salud mental de uno solo
afecta
entonces me senté un día
y pensé
es lo que yo puedo hacer
dentro de mis limitadas capacidades como
un humano más me puede permitir
maximizar un impacto positivo me permite
sentir que hago algo no simplemente que
soy una víctima sino que así sea poquito
lo que puedo hacer pero peleo nada
contra la corriente como el coi pero
bueno no me convertí en dragones
y volviendo a los japoneses ellos tienen
un concepto muy interesante que es el
icai
qué es la intersección entre las cosas
para los que uno tiene talento lo que se
le da bien
las cosas
el mundo necesita
las cosas que a uno le gustan cuales que
uno se nutre
finalmente y muy importante las cosas
por las que uno le pueden pagar
pero trabajo te gusta tanto que
pero esto es casi que un animal
mitológico es un unicornio esto es muy
difícil de conseguir yo antes lo trataba
de lograr con la ciencia tratada que en
investigación tuviera una aplicación un
impacto humano con todo lo que pasó en
venezuela yo tuve que abandonar esa
carrera pero me di cuenta que uno puede
hacer
cosas que es o indirectamente benefician
a otros
entonces yo en el final me cambié de
carrera
y encontré algo que me gustaba
que se me da bien
y por lo que me paga una cantidad que ni
en mis sueños ni en mis mejores sueños
pensé que alguna vez que llegara a ganar
porque ahora se trabaja una compañía de
silicon valley una compañía de esas
aplicaciones que el mundo no necesita
capitalistas malvadas
pero
como yo he aprendido de vivir con poco
me da lo suficiente para yo usar esos
recursos
y compartirlos con mis hermanos
venezolanos y ayudarlos a salir del
infierno porque si bien mucha gente votó
por el destructor de venezuela hugo
chávez más de la mitad de ellos no lo
hicieron y nos merecen lo que está
pasando ahora
porque yo hago esto
por qué
hace mucho tiempo cuando yo empecé a la
universidad yo era muy pobre no tenía ni
para comer más de una vez me fui a la
cama sin comer 23 veces 23 días sin
comer a veces
mi tutor de tesis cuando se entra en
laboratorio se dio cuenta de eso y me
empezó a regalar comida no tenía ninguna
obligación no éramos familiares no me
conocía bien no éramos amigos
cada mes me regalaba una bolsa de comida
me permitió enfocarme me estimuló saber
que alguien creía en mí que alguien veía
potencial y esos son favores que no se
pagan son deudas que son impagables
en vez de tratar de pagar eso prefiero
que otras personas tengan una
oportunidad similar a la que yo tuve así
sea pasando en el lado del maligno
capitalismo
y bueno eso me condujo a fundar la
organización salto
inicialmente era solo en mi propio
bolsillo da financiamiento a venezolanos
que necesitan salir del país porque
recuerden el salario mínimo en venezuela
ahora es 23 dólares un proceso
universitario gana 4 dólares con suerte
como se vive así no se puede yo veo a
mis amigos perder peso mes tras mes es
para mí eso es doloroso es traumático
la gente necesita salir
gente que dice bueno que peleen no todos
son guerreros
y bueno yo tengo aquí historias como la
del doctor josé gregorio su esposa
marlene y su hija que ahora viven en
lima menos de un año después de su
mudanza ahora el doctor josé gregorio
está a punto de revalidar su título y
empezar a salvar vidas de nuevo ellos se
mudaron a la lima con nuestro apoyo
la señora saide
era un artista ahora cuida ancianos y su
primer su primera nieta chilena acaba de
nacer
logramos ayudar a toda la familia
o juan que tenía ciudadanía española
pero no tenía cómo llegar allá y lo
ayudamos también hasta el momento hemos
ayudado casi 60 personas
y yo estoy totalmente consciente que eso
es muy poco pero para estas personas lo
ha sido todo porque muchos de ellos no
tienen absolutamente ninguna posibilidad
de salir cuando hablan conmigo me dicen
guido gracias por devolverme la
esperanza
esta foto
fue tomada en santiago
y ahora gran parte de mi familia en
santiago
los lleve a ton para que los conocieran
esta tarde yo conocí a todos ellos yo a
ninguno de ellos los conocí a algunos de
ellos los ayudamos con asesoramiento
acerca de información de los papeles en
chile a otros los ayudamos a conseguir
al departamento a otros los ayudamos
con los boletos aéreos los boletos de
bus
y para nosotros esa tarde fue muy
especial yo lloré porque veía
tangiblemente ante mis ojos gente que yo
no conocía que estaba estableciendo una
nueva vida que estaba logrando que
estaba creando que está aportando a sus
nuevos países
es muy poco
la situación empeora
son millones los que necesitan ayuda
nadie puede ayudar millones
pero se hace el intento y esta es la
manera en como yo he encontrado de
sobrevivir de persistir de conservar mi
cordura mi paz hasta mi felicidad si
puedo ser feliz
porque sé que no me estoy quedando
quieto que estoy haciendo algo
estoy haciendo una diferencia y no es
mucho lo que puedo hacer pero es algo
todos y cada uno de nosotros podemos
hacer algo por más mínimo que sea una
diferencia a alguien
puede cambiar una vida un gesto que uno
ni siquiera se da cuenta
si quieren saber más de esto se pueden
ir a nuestra página web salto
project.org
dónde van a encontrar los testimonios de
algunas de estas personas que hemos
ayudado y más información sobre nuestra
iniciativa
yo les quiero dar las gracias a las
personas que están acá
a ecuador
porque tengo primos que viven acá están
encantados con su recibimiento que están
maravillados
están muy agradecidos y yo también estoy
agradecido porque porque los venezolanos
están buscando una vida mejor
un nuevo amanecer como diría la tigresa
del oriente'
y yo quiero terminar también
tono humorístico porque parte de vivir
en una situación que uno sabe que no
tiene fin y aprender a convivir con algo
una situación política como la de
venezuela o con una enfermedad crónica
es aprender
que hay que reírse así no tenga la cara
empapada por las lágrimas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]